i mean i think it's i think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this
no i don't think anyone's going to buy
that
hey that's the stupidest person in my
life
well holy sh
you think it's too late to send it back
i ordered a lot
[Music]
defending
he's slow actual dog water
take what
attacking
can you guys take me off can you take my
office.com
can you take me off the website
take me off the website
get me off
[Music]
let's say h3 just some passing movie
bishop e6 with bishop b5 yeah that's the
downside of a5 you open up that b5
square for the bishop
isn't that cool when i predict the moves
you're gonna say because we all see
things in the same way in the same speed
on this show isn't that cool when we do
that
it doesn't make me very happy
[Laughter]
i was gonna say isn't it isn't it cool
like i feel like uh chris farley
interviewing paul mccartney remember
when you wrote that song
did you mean it um
oh it's okay danny boy it's okay danny
boy let's uh listen in on the other half
of this equation here and uh see how
ollie's feeling about things so far
we will be right back with more round
nine it's the feed day candidates
coverage here on chess.com presented by
grip6
[Music]
oh yeah boys
sorry i have to pee
mute them mute them mute them mute them
[Music]
hello yawn and magnus um great game
today another draw who would have
guessed my name is andrea reporting from
botezz live magnus i bet you're really
tired of getting a lot of really
complicated chess questions but i've
been dying to ask you how does the
knights move
um that's uh that's a good uh good
question uh it generally moves
um like an l and sometimes in blitz
games it can be very unpredictable thank
you magnus only you could answer my
question 15 moves away can he he should
not spend any time
oh my god oh and it's a big blunder
that's 46. oh my god probably six what's
happening they're moving too fast and
they are moving too fast i cannot follow
they are moving to a 60
oh
my god will we reach move 60 what is
happening and where it is going i think
he is winning and white is winning
she's winning white won a bishop
white when a bishop is key in time i
think he is 60. it's move 58
it's moving he lost on time
oh my gosh he lost some time on move 58
but i do expect the games to be pretty
close
oh my god i just got a shot into bobby
hall's outfit
he's just like oh wow it's
isn't that that looks like something
right out of the 1970s
but he's dressed like dwight from the
office
true that's true i literally
literally have the yellow tie mug right
here and he's exactly yeah bobby texted
me last night and said wait till you see
my outfit but i had no idea this was
what he was gonna do this is hilarious
it's friday friday
world championship on friday tomorrow is
saturday and sunday comes after tomorrow
is saturday and after that comes sunday
yeah and yesterday was thursday
yesterday was thursday
i got today is friday is friday yeah
okay there's someone in the front seat
which seat
did you take oh sitting in the back seat
look at the masks off literally and
figuratively they're awaiting
[Music]
so we're about to remind you of course
what that question was and what the
answer is to today's trivia question for
those of you who haven't already looked
it up and played along with us on the
socials of media as they say so don't go
anywhere
for all the media that is social we'll
return henceforth with
and we will be back with the cool kids
[Music]
get me off camera
all right that's
is that better not me
very well played yes
yes
six zero undefeated
yes baby
i did
a 360 degree view man come on
wait what do you want me to do
what do you want me to do sir
this is not
this is nothing like a drug
what do you mean this is the twerk
that is a twerk
yeah now it's like a dwelling yeah okay
oh my god what did i just see
i that's how i twerk okay
i need to sanitize my eyes once again
magnus
down in the clock as well but it doesn't
matter and the historic moment he
stopped the clock 18 year old
grandmaster andrei yasipanko just beat
the world champion in a classical game
what a game impressive game
wow
and look at him that he is exhausted
from the fight that he just brought to
the world champion but look he might cry
look at him look at him wow what we see
the emotions it's amazing 18 year old
grandmaster andre yasipanko just beat
the world champion all right i donated a
thousand dollars to his stream and
intermission uh to hopefully distract
him a little bit he's gonna be thinking
so much about their donation he's not
gonna be focused on this game of chess
triple big brain iq moves
mr b
what the
oh
my heart
i wonder i i don't know what anyone's
talking about right now
you
absolute god he said you absolute god
robert are we
looking at the same possible tactic here
yeah i don't think it works though you
don't i don't think it works so i think
i'm in on this inside joke too i also i
also see the tactic but let's
let's show it for everybody just in case
because i know you guys see the tactic
that i also see so let's show everybody
just in case they don't see it so after
d4
a4 okay obviously yep the most obvious
move for white or the most natural move
is knight to c5
maybe it's not the best movie everyone
needs you to go show a couple more moves
now we all see it
ian is still playing quickly there they
both have a healthy amount of time
and we're about to break the
world record for the longest world
championship game
we are nearing history here will it be a
decisive game today
it's
i have no idea how to answer that
question but i know that either way we
have broken history here in the 2021
world chess championship because the
move rook to d2
officially makes this game
the longest game in world chess
championship history
these two guys made it happen this is
his last chance it's going to come down
to the wire
but now king
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a force field why can't i just
jump over it right it's like an electric
fence it zaps me back if i can put the
king here we have a different position
right you ever jumped on electric fence
as a kid no right where i grew up there
there were a lot of them you keep out
like elk and stuff and you ever like run
from your friends you're playing tag and
you jump on the fence and instantly like
i've jumped on an electric fence been
shocked right off of the fence danny
that's how the king feels right now
danny that explains a lot
out about my electric fence
experience you know why
there's like some ptsd coming up
calm down danny you okay we're no longer
we're no longer in that drama
be present okay you go here here here
here here
here here here uh it's a draw so here
here here here
here here here here here here here here
here there there there and you win rook
takes knight and now queen f2 queen g2
is just game over like yeah and oh and
he's queen of two oh no oh no
oh no
queen of two logic misses it queen of
two
oh no
the only one oh we missed it and now
he's right because me ludwig is a force
maiden two and now he's made it what a
throw
king eight and then queen c8 and there's
actually a staircase checkmate oh man
logic through maybe seven's mate rookie
six squeaky sevens queen d7 there's
three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
the question is just lovely realize that
he was made
magnus your accent sounds a little bit
like thor as well just i'm a huge
marvels fan
[Laughter]
king coming closer and he knows it oh
i can't believe i just beat him oh my
god
yes
oh my gosh none of you none of you
thought i was gonna beat this man none
of you look at that that is right oh my
gosh oh
[Music]
i've done the calculations
give the camera words of inspiration
okay or just paul champs invite me back
to your damn tournament i lost it was it
was a it was
you know i made it further than you i'm
playing more than i was doing
i know it was i i had a bad setup all
right hey hold on i want to see if i can
find a way to check
king
oh wow look at this don't play upstairs
don't play it don't wait wait a second
we have a resignation we have history
i mean okay
he takes him to
what what was that he's trying to no
don't don't pre-move that that is over
oh my god he could actually steal me no
this is really really bad
do not do that because what is happening
you can accidentally stalemate if you do
this the king might go the other way
buddy
oh
oh my god uh-oh
oh no never mind no boxing no it's gonna
be a stalemate it's gonna be a stalemate
he's still there
oh my don't do it he's gonna do it don't
do it don't do it
yeah
i move
like a staircase
[Music]
you